okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolf language design review getting
ready for version 14 part of our
incremental language development series
all right the first function here
okay we get the zeroth page this was a
suggested by the AI function as I recall
correct yeah it was one of the ones that
came in through our llm tools uh and
Danny and Ian put together the the
function and ref page and we just wanted
to get a final once over oh wait a
minute what the heck is happening here
this is not letting me type here
see if this works
that worked
so this goes along with digit count
right and digits yeah I think this is
just fine
yeah we included for example supports
mixed Radix forms
so basically the sum of the yep
looks fine to me
okay
onwards quick and easy second one uh
will probably take a little more time
and that's spherical angle uh which Brad
has an example here and there's also a
ref page to see
what the heck is that thing
well it's a graph of vertices on a
sphere that has some special angle
properties actually that those are great
circles if you turn them into arcs
instead of lines
um maybe we should look at the
documentation first though because this
is kind of like a neat example that the
documentation has some more simple
things in it
so we looked at spherical distance last
for the last version right yeah we have
yes and what we did for spherical
distance is that we pretty much
implemented hyperspherical distance
and that was basically set the pattern
for what we're doing here
is that if you input
if you input coordinates that are high
dimensional it'll actually tell you in
an angle between two great circles and
it on a you know in sphere
to the spherical distance tells you can
tell you a distance on an end sphere but
so the input to this is the
specification of great circles specified
with two points is that right three
points yeah and if that the
specification for this is based on
planar angle it's very similar to planar
angle
I need to remember how planar angle
works
oh I see
yeah I haven't used planner angle very
much and I'm surprised I seemed like a
function one should be using all the
time yeah actually I did I didn't know
it existed but now that I know about it
I think it's a it is a pretty good one
to use and there's only one thing that
we found a little bit surprising about
the specification which is that if you
see the first and second usage there
um they one of them returns a sign angle
and the other does not return assigned
angle and in spherical angle
um we just made a decision of returning
the signed angle
as often as possible but what do you
mean it doesn't return to sign I mean
doesn't it they'll have to look at
you'll have to open details yeah because
there's something in details that it's
make it splits cases or something yeah
the signed angles are the
counterclockwise and clockwise and the
intent is that you use the rule form
the other ones are triangle angles which
we introduced for synthetic geometry and
those are not signed although you can
use either syntax
but the intent is the list of three
points is for triangles and the rule is
for angles between lines
that seems sensible
I mean so are you proposing something
different from the spherical case
well yeah the way that it is now
um if we can return an angle with a sign
we return an angle with a sign
but there's another thing there's
another caveat here which is that
you know the ability to get a sign for
the angle uh depends on having the
correct dimensional constraint for the
cross product so if you go up into
higher in sphere cases
then you don't have a functional cross
product anymore and the the situation is
non-orientable
so we just return to angle without a
sign in that case
I don't understand why is there not
I'm very confused lines are always
definable in a number of dimensions
yeah uh for for the end sphere we can
all um because well actually what
happens with the N sphere is it you
might not you have two great circles
they might not even intersect but in
this uh when when you specify the thing
as being
um one point from one great circle one
point from the other great circle and
then the point where the two great
circles intersect we've already sort of
circumvented that problem so hold on
hold on a second you're saying that in
on a five sphere or something great
circles do not necessarily intersect no
no they don't
huh because I and I think you can like
understand this even with the a three
sphere or a four sphere that you know
you have different copies you could once
the space is big enough you have
different copies of S2 in there and if
if the circles are on those different
copies they don't intersect
okay in four dimensions for example you
can have a plain fully perpendicular to
another plane
yeah
okay I don't understand this first note
that says that it's using the same
conventions as coordinate chart data um
right because coordinate chart data is
giving you so I mean the spherical or
hyperspherical coordinates of coordinate
chart data are extrinsic
coordinates on the sphere and you are
and right this is supposed to be
something intrinsic so I have no idea
what that note is even attempting to say
note is exactly the same as the one for
your spherical distance
so so what you said it is true it says
we are removing the radius and by that
is that's the only projection we do to
the sphere
so our coordinates are like those of
coordinates are data without the radius
the radius is always one
oh this is the the
I see so so this is for the input
yes the these are the coordinates for
inputting the points not for the answer
exactly yep
okay
so
all right so so this is the general case
of three points in geo-direction for
example one of the three points is
always the North Pole that's why your
direction only needs two points
by the way this should say it's in
Radiance it doesn't even mention that
okay thanks yeah it should
um
but yeah so maybe following Jose's
comment I think under under the
comparisons or something there probably
is a geo geo example there that would be
helpful to look at
like okay right right here
why is this an applications this should
be in in properties and relations
it's not an application of circle angle
why why is it not you're computing
the angle on the sphere I know but I
mean this is really comparing it with
well I don't know what what is it you
know it's saying that is an area so it's
saying that you can use this function
spherical angle to compute the area of a
region I know but but but you're not
supposed to we've got geofunctions to do
that this is really the comparison
between this function and the
geofunctions okay well we can move it
that's fine I think it should be
improvised in relations like it's a good
thing to have that but I just don't
think it's an application of this
function
because you know if you try to do
geology we have lots of applications for
things that you can and then compare
with the built-in function I mean that's
this is not exceptional in that case
well it's the wrong thing the
application is supposed to be things you
would use this function for not other
functions if it's the relations to other
functions put it in properties and
relations that's what that was for
the cube shouldn't be capitalized here
okay
I don't know exactly what this is looks
interesting but don't know what it is
um
oh yeah here's something good
the convention turned out to be
different because the
the mathematical
people use counterclockwise in the in in
Geo it's clockwise so yep
okay that's an unfortunate historical
thing
okay some old thing that I guess
probably Gauss had worked on where you
draw
like five great circles on the sphere
and it's possible that the you see you
get a pentagon outlined and the Pentagon
has star points on it those star points
that are on the Pentagon turn out to
have right angles it's a four joint
vertex and all those four those four
angles are 90 degrees okay
yep that's the definition of this
pentagrams is all such geometries that
have that 90 degree condition right you
see ulcers here
well you'll put them in yeah well we'll
put in the planar angle Circle distance
and the Geo stuff and the GEOS what's
good to me I mean
I well I want to talk to more about the
the signed not signed I mean there's a
utility
for you know the unsigned thing which is
why planar angle does that right and if
you want to be talking about you know
sums of angle you know some sort of
angles of triangles being greater than
pi and things like that I mean do we
really want to have this difference with
planar angle
well uh you know it's it's just a matter
of adding mod to Pi
wow all angles are defined ma 2 pi right
well
if we say spherical angle
here let me let me just understand this
if I what the heck why isn't this
working
this is the Prototype built
no it's not where is the Prototype build
okay so if I say
if I say spherical angle
oh but let me pick some random point on
the sphere
uh
let's say you need to have it in
um spherical coordinates
yeah okay that's fine I'm saying two one
here and that's my
points you want to explain you're going
to specify how these points are
specified you're not saying that
yes see yes that's the first note that
we discussed
okay but you should show that it's
explicitly Theta Phi
so I'm assuming that if I do this if I
say
I've got this triangle and I've got it
going from 2 1
to let's say uh you know 2.1
uh 2.1 one point
two
uh
you know 1.9
1.3 let's say
oh wow now now try to do reverse of that
okay but now what I want to do so I want
to take that personal input uh sorry
that first input is inconsistent with
planar angle
because
that Syntax for prolainar angle would be
the interior angle of a triangle okay so
hold on let's just get the the the sum
of the angles of the triangle okay so
this is presumably
if I'm not mistaken it's rotate left of
this thing table of rotate left of that
thing
comma and yeah am I right yep and
there's a threaded usage so you can get
all the angles just by putting that
whole thing in spherical angle okay so
zero to two here right like this yeah
okay so now let's say spherical angle of
that
okay now let's say total of that
oh splafaroo
why the heck isn't it oh I see because
it's the sum of the triangle yeah okay
so if we take these things that should
be the area right that or even though
it's got a sign on it
yeah but I don't know what that side is
doing and I I'd like to see the
following things so I'm going to take
I'm going to do this I'm going to say
here
now
crying grind grind
right I mean that's not going to have a
simple expression no I agree I'm not
sure what we're trying to accomplish
here
well yeah let me let me do what I'm
trying to do let's say plot percent
eight
D from 0 to
Pi let's say
so that's the
sum of the angles of a triangle
right which will always be greater than
pi
so this contains sorry information about
the the orientation
as You Follow the three
points
yes yes I think that the design is
different right which was right not what
the case would be for this syntax in
planar angle where it always gives you
the interior angle
yes we fully accept this is different
from planar Angle now the question is
what is more useful
but it is always giving the interior
angle
well the interior angle can be negative
um no it can be negative if you read it
backwards not in planar angle
it's it's not planar angle
yeah yeah yeah
it's got an orientation associated with
it
right like a geolite action for example
your direction always keeps the sign
Okay so
and yeah I'll I'll just say I I don't um
I don't have too much of a preference
about this about the consistency thing
um I asked Jose about it I think Jose
kind of made the decision of keeping the
sign but you know if okay so hold on
let's talk about it what do people think
about this I'm I I don't know enough to
know what the right thing to do is here
so my view on D is on this is that if we
always report the signed angle there is
a way to remove the sign but if we don't
report the sign angle there is no way to
add the sign
so that that's that's my main why don't
we say right here gives the signed angle
between the great circles blah blah blah
because there's no way to give a sign to
angle for the higher dimensional cases
right it's only 42 today we could do
what you said at the beginning have a
first line that instead of p is Theta
Phi
yeah and that specifies the case of the
two-dimensional case and there we put
sign down yeah gives the higher
dimensional and then it's you know beta
5 Theta 1 comma Theta 2 dot dot dot Phi
higher order you know higher dimension
yep
so you're still get rid of all the pqr
no no no we just add a first line with a
two-dimensional case and there we put
signed okay yeah and the rest of the
cases are
which looks good to me I mean when do we
get all the rest of the spherical
trigonometry functions
um
this one looks to me like I mean a lot
of effort has been spent on this one it
seems like it is great
but uh no it's actually it wasn't I
don't think it was too much effort
um main thing that's been the effort was
the
uh an exploration of spherical clipping
that we did
what does that mean
well like you know how we have the we
have um
big Geo country polygons
yes
um whenever we create a map projection
of the earth yep we need to chop the
boundaries yep and we we want I mean
ultimately in the long term I think we
want
um to have the mathematical version of
that algorithm
I see so what's up
go ahead well for applications to the
Geo I mean it would be really great if
we had the spherical version of that
then we could the mathematical version
we could use the mathematical version
and as opposed to the version that just
works with coordinates
well I I think that there are two parts
here so this project has the
computational part all these functions
to compute things like distances angles
areas Etc
and and then the graphical part we need
a sphere graphics and polygons Etc
and so the graphical part will be shared
with Geo but the mathematical part here
is it's more complicated because we want
exact results
Etc so it goes beyond what Geo needs or
or does yeah okay and and so that's the
part that that Brad is focusing right
now we are developing at the same time
this framework for graphical spherical
um graphics and and
um yeah and that will be short and
that's where we are working on all these
algorithms and then of course Brad wants
also some of those algorithms to work
exactly
and and it will be done for this uh
spherical part
okay the mathematical spherical part but
that's under development
all right should we move on one last
question do we envision spherical angle
getting a second argument
um like planar angle has
well let's play an angle second argument
well you can specify usually the there's
a orientation inferred by the order of
the points but you can just override
that and ask for the different
orientation or in the case of triangles
interior exterior for or full exterior
two dimensional case
Jose and I talked about it and decided
to leave it out so far okay fine
I don't think it's terrible to leave it
out for now
all right
uh one one final comment so as we
proceed with all this VR functions
should it be all spherical or sphere
because I find myself using this VR
graphics and sphere polygon rather than
a spherical Graphics sounds a bit
strange so before we move on with more
spherical functions we need to make that
decision I think it should be spherical
I think sphere
well it's a bit odd I'd always thought
they were going to be called spherical X
sort of like the difference between
plane angle and planar angle you have to
make a choice
yeah
I mean it's the adjectival form it's a
spherical angle well
I agree that spear Graphics is a well
gosh I mean that would require
what what is the family functions
well I think here we will need the
graphics itself plus The Primitives
polygon point line
and then we will have more the
computational part I was referring to
before sounds nice with spherical
distance angle yeah absolute spherical
triangles which you always call it you
don't call a sphere triangle which I
don't know what that would be
right but spherical graphics
I don't know it sounds like
if you are not referring it's the
graphics that is spherical not not a
graphics or honestly I understand I
understand but I think
I think it's going to be have to be the
spherical family
see presumably we're one day going to
have hyperbolic Graphics too
or something
and those are adjectival forms it's not
hyperbola graphics
okay
I mean we cheated with with Geo and
Astro by using the word roots right
exactly I don't I don't think we can do
that here
hmm
I really just think historical Graphics
is going to be a worthwhile very nice
function and I mean shouldn't be that
difficult to do right based on
Geographics technology
correct yes yes but fundamentally it's
all vector or vector has to work well
and that's the part where the current
Geographics is weak and and that's what
we are improving
yeah
okay but there's no base map for
spherical Graphics or presumably
yes it is really just white as Graphics
itself yeah okay
all right comap oh my gosh yep current
map income app apply I have been at
least provisionally approved as
experimental functions for version 14 I
think the main sticking point still is
if we want a different name
um but we wanted to review that but
we've been through this name for five
years I mean you know this this is the I
don't know whether I'll ever remember
how this works
but
you know
I don't know it's it's one of these
things well will it reach above the
level of you know
we look at use like map or will it get
you like through
where it yeah
I have to check the ref page every time
you want to use it
right
I think its name is as good as we're
gonna get it it satisfies some kind of
misery Minimax condition yeah
so the main question is are we satisfied
with leaving it as experimental or do we
yes okay yep that's what we should do
because it might change its name it
really isn't comprehensible people are
like what the heck is this
um
okay
okay message redirection
so this is a bit of a spin-off from
um
the general topic of of error handling
we talked last time about the general
handling packlet and one specific
utility that at least within the IOD
group we use a lot is message
redirection
um because a lot of times we're writing
a function that either has similar
argument handling to an existing
function or is built on top of an
existing function and we don't want
calls into
uh you know co-map to start issuing map
messages so we have utilities like this
level queue function that basically just
calls map on an argument to see if it's
actually a level spec and if it does
then it has to issue its the same
message over again and if it doesn't
then it carries on its merry way and so
Rick has this nice function in the
function repository that lets us
do message replacement at least for
existing messages just by applying a
rule to the
message head or the function head which
I'm sure it breaks in all sorts of
lovely ways yes there are various
caveats like if the message doesn't
exist
you know it's only defined for a
specific set of heads and you issue with
another head then you're going to get a
missing message message
does the most General case work where
you're replacing every message
from you know emanating from inside with
the head that you provided
I believe I made that work but it's been
a while since I looked at it
so that might be the most important
single case
sorry say that again
where where you want to replace
everything that shows up as a message
with a particular head
like I am comap and anything that I call
under the hood that issues a message I
want it to be co-map
associated with co-map with if that case
works
well you want you want the messages
branded with your brand
yes
what I'm maintaining is that that is the
single most important case and if that
works well that's useful
I mean even if it's only an internal
utility we need it uh often
in ild work I did make that work
actually and I put it in chat as an
example
I'm kind of confused about the name of
this function and
I I think
you're saying that within a block
any message issued within a block that
was a power message will now be a my
function message is that correct inside
this expert here any power function any
message
any message generated by power will
instead but how does the off stuff work
does the off stuff work correctly
I I doubt this works correctly in the
general case I mean no it does off work
does off work with my function
you know I believe it would if you did
off of my function with uh
like the infi tag or something like that
but it wouldn't respect off of Power
messages no I understand it shouldn't
I mean that would be correct I'm just
surprised that that can work
I actually yeah I don't actually
remember I'd have to dig into it again
and there are caveats like the the
message the power messages are not
actually getting issued so if you have
an outer function that is checking for
power to issue that message it's not
going to catch it
because it's not actually getting issued
right
I I think this function needs more
thought yeah I think it requires quite a
bit more thought but I mean I'm
the functionality is very useful to be
able to do this
will be super useful yes at the very
least it's something we should have in a
non-system context
in fact language context would be I
think the right place
you could certainly you know make a
small project of having
I can work with Rick or we can kind of
take a modification of this and have it
as an internal utility and bang on it a
bit and see you know where the edge
cases that are big problems are and
where it can be refined and even if it's
only used internally for some general
cases it at least gives us the name
totally confuses me yeah I think it
needs Head perhaps replace message head
but it's not necessarily message head
you can replace anything in the
the message expression so like the
parameters as well like that last
example there uh it's replacing the
integer parameters with some text
I mean it's really like reissue message
or something yeah that that seems like a
potentially better name
I see
I I was originally calling it message
redirect
and I just figured really made sense
because you can just give it arbitrary
replacement rules
yeah redirection makes people think
streams or something yeah
okay I'm not sure we're going to get
this solved today and I think this
should be combined with the error
handling discussion because this is a
whole yes I that's definitely part of it
yep well I yeah I don't know why this
one piece was split off before here well
but no hi
um
a discussion but we need this internally
fine but there's a time and a place and
I don't think this is it fair enough you
were originally going to cover it during
the error handling discussion and that
discussion got cut a little short we
also didn't get to talk about Fail-Safe
um but Christopher wasn't immediately
available and we weren't sure how long
the
prior points were so at least wanted to
be able to touch on them a little bit
even if it's just to say this is
interesting needs more thought we need a
bigger group to discuss it more
thoroughly or say I think this idea is
terrible and move on right I mean look
message
gymnastics is definitely a topic
an understanding
kind of you know the message mechanism
is a very old mechanism that's you know
done well over the years
but I suspect
you know formalizing some aspects of it
like
you know the whole message inheritance
from one symbol to another is kind of
it's very old
I don't know you know I don't know that
it's all right anymore and whether we
can be more sophisticated about that
and this is a very specific way of doing
that in a block of code you know reissue
the messages from a different symbol
right
uh
I would have thought message modify was
better than message replace because I
understand that there are replacement
rules
but it's still a complicated concept of
what's Happening
anyway just uh you know one small point
all right let's wrap it up
okay uh nothing else here
nope that should take care of us for 14.
okay
thanks a lot all right see you all soon
bye bye bye